росія в липні тип людини сміття за хеш
чат і свою Україну напарників
нацистської машини 1100 тис його парку
до звіра під москвою
інсценує за ідеєю інше світлове
засіки взяти арай стопу у сосни йому
вірним фінансовим розмахом ті сцени
частини на гігантські компанії з
мілітаризації русь та її купить нещодавно
права.
цей ваш інга момент місце putin himself
російський і низка і російський президент
кричить на силу та мілітаризації путін
перегін він ще весь кого посилатися на
найефективніший інструмент його за зовнішньою
політики active інструмент і форум
смуги
видвидівника парку патріот може так уже
клянуть інший але речі ви до російського
вас броня
такада монстрація сили проти видно
заплутування ми президента путина тягнути
самий, не боїсь давності армії
імідж якийсь сиріт росіян деталь з
росту і обличчя всіх нас всі хто живе в
гідний образ усіх нас усіх теж у бті
і дуже even може просто показати
тільки росія сина нас правда є на
насправді мілітаризація з успіху
моя різанина про його приклад продажів
тернового у броня бренду армія росії 6
магазині вид кривої турку Росії
головний з них просто на ставку
американського посольства в Москві біля крим
камуфляжному uudd і ось тут можна знаєте
так вже футболкою спить по сама на перинку
сирійського диктатора башара асада
it's not about for me that will help you
to get
мода без сум його за 7 spree мотатися
всерйоз
у путіна з приводу президентських виборів
і закуплено лімсу спирту вимагаючи чому
тобі дали більше ризикових поромів newer
knew me літери століть
при нами пари можу над нацистською
негайно і 70 руки там у кремлівської
змії в милу інструменталь та завали
прямо трансляція взяти арай столу на
російському державному ти чи jenek
мало рекордний рейтинг